anf
[拍手]
毎年成人式のこの時期雪になるとある女性
のことを思い出します
この女性とも子さんとしましょう
彼女は音晴れ着もいらない
式もだるいだけだから出ないって強がり
言ってました
んだけど友達たために式場に出かけて行っ
たんですよ私心配であとついてたんでその
時
雪の降る中
友達を会場の外で負けた
彼女は後になって
生まれた時に生まれたことを市役所に届け
をされてない無戸籍の人
戸籍のない人だってわかったんです
でもこのことは
と婿さんも当時知らない話でした
案内が来ないのは自分の母親が春木を用意
できないがために
案内を隠したんだと思ってたと言ってまし
た
この事をきっかけに私は無戸籍の人の支援
を始めたんです
tomoko さんの無戸籍を私が知った
のはマイナンバー制度が始まった時です
会社経営をしていた私は4年間バイトで
働いていた彼女にマイナンバーの提出求め
ます
しかし一向に提出されず
理由を問いただしたら種役所に何時気に
入っても住民票がないって言われ続けてた
んです
不審に思って
市役所に行ったった伝えられたのは
の戸籍の可能性がある
ということでした
どんなに彼女の生年月日と名前を調べても
情報が出てこないんです
実際彼女の母親に確認すると出生届を出し
てないっていうことでした生まれたことを
市役所に届けられていない彼女は実際に
生きてそこにないるのに何も彼女の実態を
証明するものがない
存在しない人となったんです
ふと人の目には姿が見えて話もできる
でも彼女がどこの誰なのか誰として誰一人
としてわかりません
この日から智子さんへの協力っていう支援
が始まりました
実に1年8カ月
戸籍ができるまでいろんな困難を乗り越え
て新しく彼女の戸籍を作るっていう形で
彼女の存在を証明できました
戸籍って
人の生まれた時から親子や兄弟の関係
結婚
本人の本人や家族の死亡に至るまでを登録
するもので日本国籍の所有を
証明する唯一の制度です
その人の歴史を一人一人家族単位で管理
する
世界中で日本だけが保持している
素晴らしい文化なんです
しかし
戸籍を持たない人が
推定1万人以上いると
明らかになってきました
こうした無戸籍の人は様々な生きづらさと
戦っています
まず戸籍のない人は小学校の入学案内が来
ません
だから小学校に行きません
戸籍のない人には保険証がありません
だから病院に行きません
もちろん例外はあります
智子さんは1年遅れで小学校に入学してて
高校まで進学しました
確かに保険証ありませんでしたが
tomoko さんのお母さんが待つ
生活保護受給者用の用紙を持って病院を
利用することができてました
でも就職や結婚てなるとそう簡単にはいき
ません
戸籍がないので正式に結婚することができ
ないんです
結婚といっても一緒に住むだけのいわゆる
事実婚の状態になりますそして
母親に戸籍がないと生まれてくる子供も
同じく戸籍がない人になってしまいます
こうして無戸籍の悲しい連鎖が続いて
しまいます
もう少し
の戸籍の人の例を紹介しますね
まずは皆さんの例です
misa さんは
フィリピン人のお母さんと正式には結婚し
てない日本人男性との間に生まれました
皆さんのお母さんには
好きに結婚している人が他に言いましたが
dv
つまり家庭内暴力を受けて避難をしてい
ました
そのためみささんを出産した後もミサさん
と新たなパートナーの存在を知られるのを
怖がって出生届を出せませんでした
それから20年
misa さんを成人し日本の法律によっ
てフィリピン人となりました
母親がフィリピン人だからです
生まれたのも育ったのも
話す言葉も日本語だし
蛇の言葉なんて全く話せないのに二十歳を
過ぎた途端に外国人という扱いになって
しまいます
逮捕されて強制的に母国
返されることがあるんです
しかしこういった出来事は防げるはずなん
ですよ
misa さんのお父さんはミサさんが
生まれたときに何とも出生届を出せないか
と市役所に相談に行ってました
またみささん自身も無戸籍の状態を何とか
しようと中学校の頃から市役所に相談して
ました
でも市役所で伝えられるのは冷い返事
ばかりでした当時の担当職員に知識が
なかったためにこうした事態になって
しまったんです
もうしあの時その時の職員さんが正しく声
をかけていてくれたら
とりまになりたいという彼女の夢はかなえ
られてたのかもしれません
減税
みささんは27歳です
戸籍がないことが原因で27年間
あらゆる苦労を強いられる2人の子どもと
真珠寸前でした
子どもたちにも戸籍がありません
難しい
私の支援によってミサさんには
住民票ができそして未成年の二人の子供に
はもうじき
それぞれ個別ですが戸籍ができます
これからの花材はミサさんが
正式に
日本に住むことを認めてもらうことそして
正式に日本人になる事です
misa さんのように何らかの理由で
出生届が出されてない人のために必要な
書類の案内がきちんと知らされていれば今
日本国内の無戸籍な人は
ずいぶん減ることと思います
次に舞さんの例です
三重県に住む舞さんには日本に住む資格も
住民票もあります運転免許証も職業もあり
ます
しかし前さんには北席がありません
無国籍です
舞さんは独身の胎児の母親を持ち日本での
国籍は大国となっています
しかし
お母さんの母国の大に出生届を出してい
ないから
彼女は
国籍がないんです
市役所の職員さんがお母さんが出した麻衣
さんの出生届の時に提出の時に一言
タイの領事館に
出生届だされましたかと
声お声かけをしてくれてたら
マイさあの無国籍は
防げたんでしょう
現在舞さんはある男性と夫婦として5年も
暮らしています
でも正式な結婚ができてません
もし国籍がない状態で子供が生まれたら
どうしたらいいのか
不安で舞さんは
前さんそそが市役所に相談に行きました
そこで告げられたのは子どもを産むことは
控えるようにっていう
言葉でした
自分の子孫を残すことを否定されたんです
もしその時に
赤ちゃんがすでに舞さんのおなかの中にい
たら同じことをその職員さん言えたん
でしょうか
産むことを控えろとは
妊娠ステイてもその赤ちゃん諦めて命を
奪ってまで
そういったことを支持してるんでしょうか
そもそも人間である以上誰しもが与えられ
ているはずの権利を職員さんの一言でバレ
子供を慈しんで育み将来の夢は希望を持つ
ことさえ許されないっていうんでしょうか
子孫を作ることは他人に指図されることで
はないと私は思います
まいさん夫婦は
1年近く市役所に相談言っていますが一度
も向き合って相談に乗ってもらえたことが
ありません
前例がない
先例がない
この一言で帰らされていました
無戸籍者が
市役所に相談に行くとよくいわれるのが
この前例がないという言葉です
何十年も
苦しんだ1この一言で片付けてしまいます
市役所に行けば前例がないので法テラスに
入ってください
法テラスに行けば
前例がないので
弁護士費を安くするには
生活保護の手続きが必要です
市役所で相談してきてください
市役所に戻れば戸籍や住民票のない人の
生活保護の手続きは前例がないのででき
ません
法テラスに相談して来てください
ただいまーしです
こんな調子では問題は全く解決しません
してい
ここには他の問題も隠されています
弁護士費用をね
やすくするために
生活保護の手続きを進められることです
無戸籍の人が弁護士を必要とする場面は
たくさんいます
冒頭に話した
tomoko さんの戸籍を作る申し立て
をする時には
彼女の年齢を特定できる何かの資料の提出
が必要でした
しかし
tomoko さんの母親が協力を拒否し
ていたために弁護士の力が必要となりまし
た
戸籍がないことを解消したければ生活保護
を受けなさいでは乱暴すぎます
そもそも生活保護とは特定の人が何らかの
理由で支援が必要になったとき生きづらさ
の
防ぐための一時的な生活自立支援のはず
です
弁護士日を優遇してもらうためで使う集団
では意味が違います
実際智子さんや前さんは職を得て社会で
活躍してたんです
生活保護を受けるために仕事を辞めざるを
得ないとか社会に出てできている彼女たち
の立場がなくなるとかそういった不利益を
伴うのでは寮生が国民に行う支援とは到底
思えません
最後に
日くん
みちくんという男性の例です
ミチ君は生まれて30年以上も社会から
隔離されて生きてきました
あれは生まれた数字つ後に拾われたとされ
てて
終章届も出され疲れを拾った家族が拾った
ことを隠して内緒で育ててきました
家から出ることはできず義務教育も受けて
ません
30歳を過ぎるまでずっと家の中で隠され
て暮らしてきたので働くことも知りません
彼のように働くことを知らない人間にも
戸籍を作る時生活保護を受ければ弁護士日
を免除される仕組みがあると案内されます
働くことの喜び
仲間ととは楽しい時間
お給料を手にしている自信ややる気ッ達成
感など労働に関わる様々な想いを知る前に
自分の将来への湯を亡くされてしまうん
です
こういった安易な方法は人間としての
生きる喜びを知るって言う権利を奪うやり
方ではないでしょうか
私は
無戸籍の人は
生活困難者だと位置付けます
生活高級車や生活コーナー者というと普通
二食住など物質的に困っている人のように
思われます
しかしそれだけではありません家族から
排除され
義務教育などの教育を受けられず健康保険
や年金などの公的者福祉制度も受けられず
就職困難で友人がいなくてそして何より
自分なんかどうせ相手にされないからと
自らじゃあ自分を社会から遠ざけてしまう
こんな無国籍の人の生活困窮者です
行政は物質的に困った人のための就職支援
はしていますでも無戸籍の人に対する就職
支援は全くしてませんなぜなら
就職に必要な
働くために必要なマイナンバーがないから
です
その結果として待っているのは法律を度が
s したロード女性に嫌な仕事を強要する
飲食て1日15時間もの労働を敷いても8
時間分しか計算しない会社
40度以上の高温の中防護服を着せられて
拷問のように働かされああああああそんな
職場
しかせ立ち向かおうと声をあげることは
できませんただでさえ少ない収入を
もめ事を起こしてさらに減らすことでき
ないんです
世間一般の方この普通の生活が送れない
誰も何もしてくれない助けを求めれば迷惑
そうな態度を取られる仕事はないだからお
金がないたとえ仕事があっても自分で選べ
ない苦痛を伴う労働しかない何もいいこと
はない
こうなると
こうなると誰かに助けを求められなくなる
精神は疲れ果てて生きる気力すら奪われて
いきます
一人で頑張れなくなるんです
戸籍がないのは本人の責任ではありません
かといって親の責任でもない
誰の責任でもありません
の戸籍ができるこういった状況があること
に悲しみを覚えます
それを踏まえて無戸籍の人とその家族の版
送信つまり責任を持って一緒に行動を
起こすという支援をしています
市役所に行けなくなった
一緒についていきます
職員さんに事情説明
私がします
各行政市場の請求も私がします
行政からの報告や支持は私が代わりに受け
ます
交渉事の家庭裁判所もそれに伴う手続きも
一つ一つ本人と家族と一緒に乗り越えます
学校に行ってなくて字が書けない私が脱出
します
生活ができるようになるように行政と本人
と一緒に考えます
前例がないからって言われても前例を作る
べく踏ん張ります
私が支援を始めてから
約この5年で無戸籍の人の生きづらさが
多くを知りました
無戸籍の人の状況
悔しさ悲しに諦め見過ごされる立場苦しい
生活
失う夢持てない規模いろんなことを知らへ
裏ましたそれを知った今しランカーをする
ことはできません
そっぽを向いて楽をすることは責任感から
わたし自身をも苦しめることになります私
が知らない顔したばかりにその人は命を
失ってしまうんじゃないか
苦痛を長引かせているんじゃないか大きく
成長するはずの小さな命が奪われるのを
防げたんじゃないか
私の存在が人の命を守る役目を果たすので
あればやっ後悔しないように精いっぱいの
努力を惜しまないことがわたし自身を大切
にすることになると思います
そして無戸籍の人と共に混乱を乗り越える
悦びを知りました
存在しないとと言われ続け
生きることをあきらめて
どうやって楽に死ねるのか
そんなことを考えながら生きてきた人その
人たちと一緒に
その1-5的証を探し
目標を一つ一つ達成していく
市役所の職員さんと一緒に前例のないこと
を一緒にやり遂げて
明日 s take
一緒に前例をつくっていく
一緒に頑張った無戸籍の人が自分の生きる
意味に気づいて将来を考えることができる
ようになった時どれほど嬉しいことか
とに気持ちがいっぱいです
だから
だからどうかどうしたら無戸籍の人が生き
ていけるのか
今日の皆さんはじめ行政の人の職員の人に
は何かの手だてを一緒に考えてほしい
前例がないことはやらないなんてルールが
あるはずがないんです
初めて相談に訪れた無戸籍の人の最後の
いける気力を奪うことがないようにと願っ
ています何より差別をしないで同じ人間と
して同じ権利が受けられるよ無戸籍って
いう立場の理解を必要としています
私はいつも相談に来られた無戸籍の人に
会うとこう言います
大変だったね
生きてきてくれてありがとう
よかったよ勇気出して私のとこ相談に来て
くれて
これからは
一緒に解決していけるね
教育や仕事
結婚などさまざまなことその人の人生が
戸籍のあるとかないとかで差別されない
社会が
つか来ることを願っています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]